wait no I disagree no I don't think you
will be but I might be but pretty the
feeling on the show I don't want this to
be a magnum p.i yeah we'll just touch
upon it right after what I want to talk
about Cobie I want to talk about yeah
man did we sad about that oh my god it
like it was it it [ __ ] me up in a way
that I was it was unexpected me too yeah
I still think about it every day
so do I it's crazy you you know Kobe
Bryant so I didn't know who he was but I
didn't I wasn't as aware but it
obviously like Jay was like and everyone
was super upset about it so yeah it's I
don't know i'm not i don't i'm not a
Laker fan I have to say it I live in LA
okay I found a basketball like I don't
like basketball I don't like sports ball
which is fun yeah which is fine right
but it's not the fact that he was a
legend he is a legend in NBA but it was
just the way it happened
and just the way here's wife and his
family I mean it's just so sad
just the whole the way the whole thing
went down and and it's just I don't know
man because my dad died in August and I
guess you know I mean I I just I just
feel bad I just feel fair em empathy for
the family it's it's also you know the
combination of both losing two members
of your family like that and knowing
that I don't know I just so I think it's
I know I just left I don't know I just
I mean that's what you do you're a
comedian right yeah when [ __ ] is
uncomfortable yeah making uncomfortable
feelings no I when he gets real I giggle
just because of a defense mechanism but
it's not because I am mocking about the
comedian who tweeted but he tweeted
about Kobe Bryant like 10 minutes after
his death no oh my god so he's done our
podcast he knows that he's he knew that
his name is Ari Shaffir and he tweeted
something along the lines of Kobe is a
rapist
whoever forgot to put gas in that
chopper is a hero or something are you
serious yeah and his daughter died yeah
[ __ ] the lit and then like a video he
did a video as well like yeah 21 to 21
years too late or some Kobe died 23
years too late too late yeah yeah well
you know I'm not even gonna go into that
whole the other side of things but the
man just died with his [ __ ] daughter
and his family like [ __ ] that guy guys
just trying to like capitalize on a
moment now like we're talking about him
other people who never knew who he was
gave his [ __ ] about him for 10 minutes
[ __ ] that I know but I had to say
doesn't beat Bobby up three times he
kicked me in the face 50 times oh my god
sounds like a sweetheart but the thing
is is that he's because he hangs out
with everybody he's not just some
unknown guy he's a Joe Rogan's
right-hand guy yeah he's he's always at
the clubs I've known him for 20 over 20
years everyone how does he get to come
to be kicking you in the face 50 times
Oh God darío starsk it was over a girl
but not a girl that Bobby Bobby sided
with the guy no that's not what happened
Oh
the real stories coming out essentially
it's this okay all right so do you know
who know Tasha Leggero is yeah you know
she yeah
she used to date him hmm they live
together and they were in love okay they
were making sweet he was a big Jewish
guy boinking her with a dude a bike on
my right and then what happened was from
Canada right who saw it for a perform at
The Comedy Store and he goes I want a
blank on go who uses the word point was
the 1950s a that anyway so I he he
caught her he got her number behind my
back even though I told him that she's
living with my friend Ari yeah and
eventually she leaves him mm-hmm
my for you for the pointer for Canadian
bunk bunk all right right so they say a
different and Canadian blinking very
good patina so then what happened was he
he calls me one day he's crying and he
goes she loves me I go I'm so sorry and
he goes did you set them up because no
one knew him except for me and I go no
why would I [ __ ] do that because well
because he was on cast member on MADtv
when I was on MADtv and he asked me to
break into Ron's office to steal the
emails between Natasha and the sky right
who
[Music]
private investigator yeah so then what
happened was I go I'm not gonna do that
you go go then you set them up so the
next night I was at which is logical
thank you thank you you're siding with
them but then the next I [ __ ] checking
in at you know cuz we go to the comedy
club you have to check in at the at the
booth and I said I'm Bob I'm here and
then all of a sudden i black out Oh
chief shot at you from behind yeah and
then what your place of work yeah at the
comical store Frankie so I'm on the
ground
and he kicks me in the face like 50
times
right and then drunk no just full of
rage lot of kind of shoes there are very
soft and so what happen Steve Rannazzisi
you know who he is he's Steve Rannazzisi
he was a comedian that lied that he was
in 911 and he wasn't so he kind of
watched it happen to you didn't really
help me and gave you a heads up at least
well even worse when you wanted to call
the cops he pulled the phone off of the
wall right yeah so I try to call the
cops
yeah he pulled it off so then but then
Steve had a group he's still he's done
our podcast was on the league so he had
a very successful career and re so then
at the ray Ari and made amends to me
years later he had a show called this is
not happening on Comedy Central a
storytelling show and he I did it three
times you know so